allez excellent que le génie en
spectacle plusieurs fois je les ai reçus
plusieurs fois rtl elle bien faire des
mais franchement aller remarquable il ya
fait un sketch notamment elle parle de
son père où aller un style dans l'école
de son père c'est à tomber de rire allez
formidable us alors je ne sers à kaduna
zaria blot talent je l'aimerais remet ça
change un peu aussi des halles un talent
fou voilà alors umaga du mois moi j'ai
je ne suis pas là pour juger ses
soudures sont son talent d'artiste mais
en tout cas moi j'ai un problème avec la
définition la définition des missions
c'est incroyable talent je suis pas sûr
que le fait d'être humoriste soit
vraiment appris à bassin versant parce
que moins d'un incroyable j'entends le
spectaculaire et j'entends elle est
telle que très drôle d'époque c'est
spectaculaire d'avoir très drôle mais
moi pas forcément m'a pas forcée - la
valeur est très subjectif c'est
compliqué vu du spectaculaire j'en ai
maintenant des choses vraiment voilà
grâce à dire des magiciens croyable
étalons j'ai voyagé par une surprennent
devrait super talent on voit la vraie
alors qu il trouve que c'est mérité
alors oui c'est mérité franchement elle
leur sauve la saison parce qu'à la vue
moral à quelque chose
le reste était nul c'était une imminence
d équilibriste à la mord moi le noeud
c'était nul mais ça me pose un problème
c'est que c'est déjà un professionnel
révélations on prend quelqu'un qui fait
déjà de la cena télé j'ai un peu
d'accord normalement alors aidez-moi je
rappelle y avait une émission qui
s'appelait graines de stars là c'était
vraiment des gens à wiki éthique et hong
kong et shanghai n'est pas exactement si
désolée incroyable talent s'il vous
plaît avec un côté que des anonymes que
des personnes inconnues la meuf elle
rempli le palais des glaces jusqu'en
nos relations publiques elle a pris ses
fanatiques qui ont voté elle est très
drôle elle et grinçante elle est assise
légale sauf qu'ils ont galéré par
westinghouse
mais oui sur la possible il y avait il y
avait le premier groupe qui est
extraordinaire il y avait plein de gens
avec un talent extraordinaire de voir ce
que j'ai le droit un peu talent là je
vous rejoins le dealer j'adore cet
article oui mais je veux des gens moi je
le boulanger week est excellent et qui
est vraiment très drôle - you re a
plongé il n'a jamais fait de scène il
arrive et on lui trouve un talent
comique exceptionnel voilà ça ça me
plaît ça serait après tout le monde la
connaissait pas moi j'avoue
et on l'a découverte aussi et elle a un
humour quand même les émissions de
télévision pour l'accueillir
je pense que les gens ont adhéré à sonia
grinçant bas voilà dans ses affaires
après les dernières c'est un mec juste
derrière celle à venir d'ailleurs nous
voir la semaine prochaine avec grand
plaisir ce qu'elle est vraiment
formidable oui alors des sketches ce
formidable site ou ailleurs avait du
second degré ça serait depuis un
interrupteur à du second degré arrêté
huit heures c'est très intéressant pour
voir en revanche effectivement cette
émission terminée elle a perdu un
million de téléspectateurs
tétouan mais pour ce qu'ils veulent tu
peux faire des erreurs a désossé
nouvelle star avait 500 milles
non mais quand il n'y a pas la joie mais
là il a raison
pamela réseau citepa vieri reste pas tu
risquerais nationale chéri vous avez 22
dans le cdi vous vers onze années cdi
ça va leur faire des millions là je
finis en une phrase oui qu'est-ce qu'on
a découvert finalement que la seule
chose qui intéressait les gens c'était
de voir un méchant qui se foutait de la
gueule des autres et qu'il est à claix
vous enlevez rauzan permanente et c'est
d'ailleurs avec cherche un méchant pour
l'an prochain mais je pense qu'on a dit
il cherche un méchant théo si je peux
donner mon opinion j'ai adoré
franchement c'est mon coup de coeur de
cette saison je les trouvais franchement
remarquable fallait oser certaines
certaine morale franchement elle a géré
même sur sa dernière prestation là j'ai
l'impression d'organes dans les paroles
elle a réussi à à chercher le public à
chercher les votes sans faire la force 2
et franchement j'ai adoré félicitations
à non mais